Justice.
That is a good one.
Let's circle back to young people,
um,
because the future is going to
belong to them before we know it,
Huh?
Uh,
remarkable and a very insightful
and engaging human being.
Jonathan Height is perhaps a,
a leading example of somebody who's
seen from a left perspective himself.
How dangerous all of his ears on how we're
endangering young people by not being
honest with them,
not encouraging them to,
to explore what they instinctively feel
needs to be explored going back to our
earlier topic and when leaving
them without the resilience
that they're going to
need to confirm if you like a
free and prosperous society.
And A,
I had a question he would
run relating to this,
which I'd just like to read,
uh,
in his piece of the coddling
of the American mind.
Jonathan Heit outlines why millennials
today are so fragile and lacking
resilience in life and in relationships,
in university courses in the workplace,
and what has led to this overwhelming
push to be protected from anything
difficult or uncomfortable or offensive.
And he calls it the flight to safety.
And I think you've used that expression.
Um,
he outlines the core reason for
this fragility of mind and emotion.
He says it stems firstly
from overfunctioning and
over protective parents.
Then schools now reaches
into our universities and
of course more people than
ever.
I go to universities in the west,
so they formed a much bigger bulk in our
community afterwards and at least some
tragically unprepared and unarmed
for life and relationships.
Would you comment on,
I think it's good to take a step back
from that and think about it in the
broadest possible terms.
There is definitely an epidemic
of over protective parenting,
but it's useful to ask why.
And my suspicions are,
is that this is driven by very fundamental
biological and cultural phenomena
that aren't generally considered
in relationship to this issue.
We don't have very many children.
We don't have
12 you know,
six of whom died.
We have one or two
that makes them very precious,
right?
We're unwilling to take risks
with them and no wonder.
And then we also have
the much later in life.
And so like if you have a kid
when you're 18 you're still a kid.
You know you're going to
go out and have your life,
right?
Because you're so while you were in the,
in the height of your exploratory,
you're,
you're in the height of the
exploratory part of your life.
You're not going to overprotect
your kid because you're still a kid.
But if you're 40 and have one child,
it's like all your eggs are in one basket.
And the probability that you're going
to take undue risks with that precious
person is very,
very low.
Now obviously there's some
advantages to that because great,
you would devote resources to your child,
you know,
and foster their development.
But the downside is that you have every
motivation to hover and maybe you're
also extraordinarily desperate as a mother
to maintain that bond with your child
because you've struggled
so long to achieve it.
It's a highly,
highly valuable,
you can't take a risk.
Well,
so these,
so we might say,
well,
perhaps over protective parenting is a
secondary unintended consequence of the
birth control pill.
And the fact that people now have
children later in life could easily be,
you know,
if you have six kids,
it's like,
what are you going to do?
Hype helicopter,
parent them.
It's like,
no,
you're so tired.
You can't even get off the couch.
If you have six kids and they're,
they outnumber you,
right?
They're raising each other.
They're competing and they're
taking each other down a peg.
They're not,
there's no overprotection there,
but with the,
with a single child landscape
or dual child landscape,
mostly a single child landscape,
then you're going to overprotect and
then that ethos starts to permeate the
schools and it starts to permeate the
higher education institutions as those
children mature,
and then that all reinforces it.
Not Good.
It's not obvious what to do about
it either because if it is driven by
demographics in that,
in that sense,
it's a much more intractable
problem that we think.
So I did some of that
in 12 rules for life,
you know,
I said,
look,
what you have to understand is that
you're a danger to your children no matter
what.
Right?
You can let them go out in the world and
be hurt or you can overprotect them and
hurt them that way.
So you,
here's your choice.
You can make your children competent and
courageous or you can make them safe,
but you can't make them safe
because life isn't safe.
So if you sacrifice their courage and
competence on the altar of safety,
then you disarm them completely and all
they can do is pray to be protected.
So in the very act of trying
to do the right thing by them,
although often with a selfish motive
right off of the surface mining,
we
strip why the tools and the equipment
and the understanding they really need to
make life work.
Well,
that's the,
that's the DePaul mother,
right?
That was for great discovery of the
dark mother and the dark mother is the
person.
She's the witch in Hansel
and Gretel gingerbread house.
Lost children too good to be true.
It's like a house of candy.
Wow.
Who could want anything better?
What lives inside the House of Candy,
the which that wants to
fatten you up and eat you.
Right.
A cautionary tale about
over protective parents,
over protective mothers,
about the over protective feminine.
It's like the psychoanalysts,
they were so said,
the good mother necessarily
fails at such a brilliant phrase.
It's like you can't,
as you,
as your child matures,
you have to fail more
and more as a mother.
Right.
Until by the time you're 30 you're your
child's 30 let's say 25 for that matter,
you're not their mother anymore.
I mean obviously you are,
but the relationship has hit
something like quasi peer status,
not entirely obviously,
but the child is independent,
able to stand up on their own
two feet and take on the world.
Okay,
now we say this thing or the university
student runs into some difficulties with
study or whatever and it brings the
parents in to talk to the faculty.
Yeah.
Or they go off in color.
I mean when I went to Queens University
a week ago and there was a lot of noise
and and horror around that,
you know that the people who were
decrying my visit set up coloring book
stations so that people could be comforted
because you know the evil professor
was coming to talk.
It's like,
and you know as a clinician and height
knows this as well and all the clinicians
worth their salt.
No,
this the worst thing you can do for
someone who's anxious is overprotect them.
It makes them worse.
The clinical literature
on that is crystal clear.
What you do for people who
are hyper anxious is gradually
expose them with their
voluntary consent to increasingly
threatening situations that cures them.
It's exactly the opposite of what all
the mental health professionals so,
and I use that term extraordinarily
lightly or trying to do to produce safe
spaces on the university campus.
Like if a safe as if it's space
needs to be defined as safe.
You can be sure that's the one thing.
It is not
drove and this has been fascinating.
Let me pay you a compliment.
In some ways,
I think the most valuable thing you can
do for us is to model the courage to
speak your mind.
You do it forcefully,
you do it courageously,
you do it compassionately because the
reality is you only have to spend a bit of
time with you to realize
that you actually care,
especially about our young people
and what they're experiencing.
And especially for our young men because
we know boys model themselves are men
who they respect
you.
They are great job of modeling
courage in the face of it.
Well,
there's something I like to say
maybe in closing about courage.
People say that to me and you know,
I don't think it's exactly right.
There's a,
there's a line in the Old Testament,
the fear of God is the beginning of
wisdom and I think it's more like that.
It's not that I'm courageous,
it's that I'm afraid of the right things.
So when I made my videos,
it wasn't like that
didn't make me nervous,
but I was less nervous about going back
to bed and not saying what I had to say,
that I was about making the videos
because I know where this is going.
I don't want to go there.
And so it's,
it's not so much courage.
It's that it's a matter of,
uh,
it's,
it's less risky to say something
than to remain silent when,
you know,
there's something to be said.
I know that to be the case.
And so lots of times in life it's like
there's no pathway forward that's going
to shield you from risk.
You get to pick this risk or
you get to pick this risk.
And I think I picked the lesser
risk and that might be wise,
but I'm not so sure it's courageous.
Well,
I think it's admirable.
Let's leave it on that basis.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the conversation.